yeah I know red shirt right it's a lot
of red the red is the color of anger the
good news it's over now so there that is
[Music]
president evil the final chapter buh-bye
so Resident Evil the final chapter or
the poster calls it true is the supposed
final chapter in the Resident Evil movie
franchise which is great news because
now they can reboot it in a completely
justified reboot in which case they can
actually follow the story from the games
that it might actually be good at it
just play the games let the movies die
point is now alice is back just do stuff
and stop umbrella again I say it like
that because for a large chunk of this
movie I was sitting there like why is
anything happening right if the movie is
self-aware the fact the audience really
doesn't know why any of this is
happening because they fill in the
audience like eight by the way here's
what's happened this is what happened
before and now here's where we are and
even what happened before isn't actually
in line with what happened before from
what I remember I say from what I
remember in my disclaimer the fact that
I've seen the Resident Evil movies once
in theaters each so I might be
remembering it wrong but from what I can
recall in the second Resident Evil movie
Jerrod Harris's character was the one
who created the t-virus and the Red
Queen which was the AI robot in the hive
was modeled after his daughter right
this one it tells us a completely
different guy who made the t-virus and
that guy's daughter is what the Red
Queen is modeled after was really
confusing if they're a Resident Evil
movie fans out there who completely just
watch these movies all the time and
knows the Lord please clear it up for me
because I'm trying to remember a movie
that I saw like 13 years ago once the
movie it's just a series of action
sequences it's like alright action
sequence and Ellis is knocked out now
she's in a completely different scenario
and then action sequence you guys
knocked out again now she's in a
completely different scenario this is
how you transport people in movies I
guess you just knock them out another
somewhere else and this goes on for like
two-thirds of the movie I always bored
out of my [ __ ] mind as I was watching
this movie reflecting back to the
Transformers movies that I really loved
like Transformers Revenge of the Fallen
and the fourth one that I can't what's
it called anyhow those are the two
Transformers movies I consider the worst
and I was just like at least they
attempted to have a story this is just
action nonsense [ __ ] just on the
for the sake of wool people like that
right problem is we live in this
technological Wonderland where we have
something called the Internet where if
we just want to watch an action sequence
we can watch one on YouTube we use
YouTube action sequence for shits and
giggles boom and now you're watching an
action sequence that shouldn't be enough
for people to buy tickets to go to the
movie theater you need characters and
story you need something in there with
it man Randy this movie attempts to have
a story by the end you'll see the
attempt to actually focus that out but
it is too little too late at that point
manage design and this concept of just
being action nonsense for the sake of
action nonsense would only be irritating
if it well my god you have not seen
shakey cam action nonsense until you've
seen it on the big screen in IMAX 3d
folks bring the migraine pills a big
ones coming trust me you can't see
what's happening not only the shaky
cream can see shake this just jump cut
is it alright I know I use jump cuts in
my youtube videos yeah if I'm talking
about a movie I use jump cuts so [ __ ]
what it's fine if it was talking if it's
an action sequence in 3d it hurts and
again maybe my jump cuts hurt you I'm
sorry if that's the case I apologize in
the meantime enjoy the free content
seriously at a point Alice and something
else they were fist fighting I was just
counting the cuts and I was like one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
you literally count the edits and I'm
like you can't see [ __ ] there were a
couple times someone died and I was like
I don't even know who died I'm going to
have to see the next scene where they're
all standing around and find out who's
not there it's like anisette who died
probably not the approach to movie once
attack I'm just saying it's not like I
said the last third it's like the movie
started to go okay guys we really got to
try I mean the studio wants us to at
least try so you see an attempt and
really in the last tenth of the movie
you can be like hey that's them trying
put it ain't enough man it's just by
then I checked out there's a part of me
that's like you know this might be the
best resident evil' ever because it's
over now part of me just wants to give
it awesome tacular because it signifies
transcendence we're going somewhere else
now I don't have to do this anymore I
found this to be a movie built on the
brick and mortar of this jump-cut shoddy
ass shaky cam action scene nonsense that
was just I couldn't ski what was
happening and I had a headache by the
first quarter of the movie like everyone
was like nah the stories aren't working
out let's
just have [ __ ] happen and yes that
should be the tagline on the poster
resident evil the final chapter
[ __ ] happens in fact dog [ __ ] happened
I'm glad it's done I'm glad it's over
bury it in the ground good riddance hi
guys so Resident Evil the final chapter
have you seen what did you think about
it or was your favorite or least
favorite or both Resident Evil movies
throughout all of them whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here you want to see more
click right here to see more it's
[ __ ] over
[Music]